there's a good look at alec mills who's
towing the slab for david ross mills
against sogard has bounced around
short season terrific start for alec
mills you know what's what's deceptive
about mills
he throws it so many different speeds
that change up almost like a floater
kesten hero
ouch that's all his knuckles jam
two up two down we get to see christian
yellow step to the plate he's dhing
tonight
there it is we're off and running you
can't start a game better than that alec
mills terrific for the cubs it's windy
when he pitches
where the brewers are going in 2020 and
beyond is right on the
right arm of this guy right here facing
ian hat off to a terrific start
97 he sends it the other way brock holt
has it for the first half anthony rizzo
1-2 pitch
he rolls one over two up two down for
brandon woodruff really good straight
change up there foreign
99 and i thought alec mills was terrific
to start things off woodruff was even
better so we're bringing in this year's
first round pick mr young ed howard no
baseball this spring
for a lot of you're 18 years old
colleges didn't play either
uh what have you done and what is your
advice to get through this for guys your
age
as you see bobby hold it hold it dad did
you see this playing behind me
i see you you saw that play i'm sorry
did you see that play
man a backhand play deep in a hole it's
a strong arm right there
honey he just has fun with it man he's
so smooth he makes it look so easy
that's just hobby doing what he does
right there honestly you can't teach
that
you can just you just got to do it david
beauty digs in for the cubs i think it's
easier for a big guy like woodruff
coming out
as a starting pitcher he's come out
throwing strikes so far
that's ridiculous look at his head in
his body he's going right towards home
plate
and he's not falling off drastically
towards first base
here's jason kipnis watch when he sets
up
he is so quiet getting to where he wants
to be
it's impressive manny pena behind the
play brewers
as alec mills goes back to work now here
we are second time around
facing this guy you've gone through the
lineup you've had conversations in the
dugout
he's throwing strikes and i ain't
hitting him he's hitting his spots
guessing he's messing up this guy
somehow he is
in his wind-up freezing hitters because
he's messing up the timing and
everything else
i'm telling you greg don't jinx this man
he's throwing the ball great pitch
number 47.
incredible makes 91 look 95.
alec mills putting on a clinic a unique
set of circumstances right now
we have yet to see a base hit or a base
runner in this game
so rizzo digs in once you pitch woodrow
trying to punch him out
you see what happened will we have our
first hit of the game and we will
that one's in there that's going to be a
difficult scoring decision that was an
hour you can't give that a hit when the
guy's throwing a note
i agree with you can he get through the
fourth
[Music]
line drive to ryan gamel tracks it down
on the track absol garcia digs in the
cleanup hitter for the brewers
as the brew crew go back to work looking
for their first hit
against alec mills
and he walks in first base runner
allowed still looking for their first
hit smoke
back to work this 2-0 pitch for mills to
smoke
and it's getting off the glove into
right
first and third for the brewers and that
should be the first hit
alec mills in a jam here this will get
the first run home
of this ball game for a 6-3 double play
garcia comes in to score and the brewers
take a one-nothing lead the story
tonight has been brandon woodruff for
the brewers
on point four innings has yet to allow a
hit
he doesn't hit his spot this one in the
gap garcia gets to it
and he keeps hayward to a single the
first hit of the night for the chicago
cubs
jason kittman is trying to tie things up
for the cubs
and ken miss to center field it's down
and we're tied
base is loaded one out and ian half will
be coming to the play for the north
siders he's done
he's done he better come get him no
confidence
now he's not locating because he is he's
mentally not there
he's going to stick with woodruff it
doesn't get any easier now because rizzo
rizzo reaches out and drops one into
center field
kidneys who had the a b of the game so
far comes in the score
rbi for anthony rizzo woodruff is done
freddie peralta the 24 year old right
hander put into a bit of a jam
base is loaded one on the one-two pitch
that's a big strikeout from young
freddie peralta
so kyle schwarber digs in well done
freddie peralta terrific work
alec mills is given a two-run lead
lead off single and then a hit batter
let's see if the brewers can stretch
a few singles together as we watch
christian yellish
send this to right center field he
unloads
and just like that the brewers regain
the lead
yo i'm telling you the key all about
rhythm and timing it's now 4-3 how big
now are those two strikeouts by freddie
peralta key moment in this game
josh hader is in the ball game josh
feigley
is asked to step up and face josh
hayder one ball two strikes two outs
bottom eight bases loaded
and josh hayder gets the punch out he
needed josh hader 22 saves or four outs
or more since 2018. here's hobby baez oh
for four
no player has struck out more against
josh hader than javi baez
oh he pulled the string and threw it for
a strike
wow hater all smiles the brewers two
game losing streak comes to an end